I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, lady. Good morning, good morning.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为你制作终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是“办公室女士”。嗨，女士。早上好，早上好。
Wow, you're in a chipper mood today. I'm very chipper. I mean, I have been up since 8 a.m. with a plumber, but that didn't stop me from being excited and happy to be here. I love it. Unfortunately, Sam has the hiccups. He does.
哇，你今天心情不错啊。我心情非常好。我是说，我从早上8点就开始和水管工打交道了，但这并没有阻止我来到这里感到兴奋和快乐。我喜欢这样。不幸的是，萨姆打嗝了。他确实在打嗝。
Do you have a hiccupups cure because I have one? Hold your breath. No. No. You take ten teeny tiny sips of water. Okay. And then stop and then do it a second time. But you take the teni as sip and you swallow it completely and then you take another
你有治打嗝的偏方吗？因为我有一个。屏住呼吸。不。不。你要喝十小口水。好的。然后停下来，再做第二次。但你要喝那十小口，完全咽下去，然后再喝下一口。
tini sip. Alright, I'm going to, I'm doing it now. Okay, let us know. Alright, well, while Sam is sipping his tiny sips of water, I'm going to tell you there it is. We just are thinking, we're talking about season eight, episode six written by Daniel Chen and directed by Troy Miller. Here is your summary. Dwight sends a ripple of panic through the Scranton branch when he introduces
一小口。好吧，我要去做了，我现在就做。好的，让我们知道结果。好吧，趁萨姆在喝他那一小口水的时候，我要告诉你，就是这个。我们正在思考，我们正在讨论第八季第六集，由丹尼尔·陈编剧，特洛伊·米勒导演。这是你的剧情梗概。德怀特在办公室软件中引入了一个问责追踪装置，旨在减少犯错次数，这在斯克兰顿分公司引发了一阵恐慌。如果他们犯了五个错误，一封电子邮件就会发给罗伯特·加利福尼亚，揭露员工对他真正的看法。与此同时，盖博和达里尔为了争夺新仓库经理瓦尔的青睐而展开竞争。萨姆，怎么样了？他在喝水。还在继续。好吧。好吧，听着，关于打嗝我唯一知道的另一件事是，如果有人吓我，它们就会消失，但我并不推荐这样做。这很不愉快。吓我，它们就会消失，但我并不推荐这样做。这很不愉快。好吧，这是第一个速记事实。我有机会和编剧丹尼·陈谈论这一集。他太可爱了。他告诉我，他们在这集中探索的核心情感是
an accountability tracking device to the office software meant to reduce the number of mistakes being made. If they make five mistakes, an email will go out to Robert California revealing what the employees really think of him. Meanwhile, Gabe and Darrell compete for the affection of new warehouse manager Val. Sam, how's it going? He's sipping. It's still going. Okay. All right. Listen, my only other thing I know about hiccups is that if someone scares me, then they go away, but I don't recommend it. It's unpleasant. scares me, then they go away, but I don't recommend it. It's unpleasant. All right, here is fast-fag number one. I got to speak with writer Danny Chan about this episode. He is so lovely. He told me that the core emotion that they were exploring with this episode was
德怀特感到不被赏识。哦，丹尼说他真的很喜欢那些探索德怀特敏感性的剧集，以及他的感受如何以一种扭曲和奇怪的方式表现出来，因为他引用“无法进行正常的表达”。丹尼还说，编剧们非常清楚帕姆是真正了解德怀特的人。他们确保在这一集中也体现了这一点。是的，我很喜欢所有这些场景。我一直都很喜欢。丹尼还提到，就这一季而言，他们确实在谁是主线故事的主角之间摇摆不定。在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔还在的时候，主角总是迈克尔·斯科特。他几乎完全是我们故事的主角。对。
Dwight feeling underappreciated. Oh, Danny said that he really loved episodes that explored Dwight's sensitivity and how his feelings manifest in a kind of twisted and weird way because he's quote incapable of normal expression. Danny also said that the writers were very aware that Pam is the person who really understands Dwight. And they made sure to have that come out in this episode as well. Yeah, I enjoyed all of those scenes. I always do. Danny also mentioned that in terms of this season, they were really toggling a lot between who was the subject of the A story. With Steve Corral, it was always Michael Scott. He was pretty much exclusively our A story. Right.
但这一季，他们想依靠不同的角色。丹尼说，我们这一季拍摄时间表的好处之一是，编剧们能够实时弄清楚情况并获得反馈。就像我们在拍摄一集、播出、感受反馈方面并没有领先太多，编剧们喜欢他们可以在未来的剧集中调整事情的事实。是的。基于这些反馈。
But with this season, they wanted to lean on different characters. Danny said one of the benefits of our shooting schedule this season was that the writers were able to figure things out and get kind of feedback in real time. Like we weren't that far ahead in terms of shooting an episode, having it air, feeling the feedback, and the writers liked the fact that they could kind of adjust things in future episodes. Yeah. Based on that feedback.
这就是他们这一季所做的大部分工作。他说，所以你会感觉到的。你会感觉到他们像是在尝试一些事情，然后觉得，哦，也许那行不通，或者尝试一些事情，然后觉得，哦，是的，我们在这里找到了方向。所以我认为这对于整个第八季来说是一个非常有趣的想法。绝对，我现在重温时会记住这一点。第二个速记事实是关于我们本周冷开场中播放的歌曲，半音速合唱团的《闭店时间》。
And that was a lot of what they were doing this season. And he said, so you're going to feel it. You're going to feel them like trying things and then being like, oh, maybe that didn't work or trying things and being like, oh, yes, we've found something here. So I thought that was a really interesting thing to think about just in terms of season 8 as a whole. Absolutely, I'm gonna have that in mind now as we rewatch. Fast fact number two is all about the song that plays in our cold open this week, closing time by semi-sonic.
你知道，当我们讲到冷开场时会进行剖析，但这首歌是其中很重要的一部分。你知道安迪会走来走去唱这首歌，他在关掉办公室。我们收到了很多关于这首歌的邮件，这超级有趣，而且都是我不知道的事情。让我们听听看。首先，来自威斯康星州科尔法克斯的科比·S说，半音速合唱团的主唱兼主要词曲作者丹·威尔逊在
You know, we'll break down the cold open when we get to it, but this song is a big part of it. You know Andy's gonna walk around seeing this song, he's closing up the office. We got a lot of mail about this song and it was super interesting and it's all stuff I did not know. Let's hear it. First of all, Kobe S from Cole Faxe Wisconsin said, Dan Wilson, the main songwriter and frontman for the band Semisonic, wrote the song when
他的妻子怀上第一个孩子时写了这首歌。他说人们经常认为这首歌是关于被酒吧赶出来，但实际上它是关于从子宫里被赶出来。什么？是的。来自威斯康星州密尔沃基的詹妮弗·T说，我当时正在听播客《歌曲解析》，2020年1月的第176集。如果你不熟悉，
his wife was pregnant with their first child. He said people often think that this song is about being bounced from a bar, but it's actually about being bounced from the womb. What? Yeah. And Jennifer T. from Milwaukee, Wisconsin, said, I was listening to the podcast Song Exploder, episode 176 from January 2020. If you aren't familiar,
《歌曲解析》邀请音乐家剖析一首歌，讲述这首歌是如何诞生的故事。关于《闭店时间》的那一集没有让人失望。自从我了解了背景后，我对这首歌的看法完全改变了，我很惊讶它竟然如此甜蜜和感人。詹妮弗接着说，基本上主唱丹·威尔逊有一个非常早产的女儿，不得不在医院里待了近一年。这首歌是在那个时候写的，当时
Song Exploder features musicians, breaking down a song and telling the story of how a song came to be. The episode about closing time did not disappoint. My perspective of the song has completely changed since I've learned the background and was surprised how sweet and touching it is. Jennifer goes on to say basically lead singer Dan Wilson had a very premature daughter that had to spend almost a year in the hospital. The song was written during that time when
医生鼓励他休息一下，不要一直待在医院，继续过自己的生活，而他们带女儿回家的那天，巧合的是，正是这首歌发行的日子。哦，天哪。所以我有一些音频片段，因为我觉得听这首歌并结合这些新信息来听歌词会很有趣。它温暖了我的心。
the doctors encouraged him to take a break from being at the hospital and keep living his life and the day they got to take their daughter home, coincidentally, was the day the song was released. Oh, my goodness. So I have a couple of audio clips, because I thought it would be fun to listen to the song and hear the lyrics with this new information. It just warmed my heart.
《闭店时间》就像是，我们要离开这家医院了。是的。好吧，这是第一个片段。闭店时间，打开所有的灯，照亮每一个男孩和每一个女孩。你听出来了吗？我知道我想带谁回家。宝宝要和她的妈妈爸爸回家了！是的！是的！
Closing time was like, we're out of this hospital. Yeah. All right, so here is clip number one. Closing time, turn all of the lights on over every boy and every girl. Do you kinda hear it? I know who I want to take me home. The baby is going home with her mom and dad! Yes! Yes!
好的，听听下一个片段。闭店时间，是你该去你想去的地方的时候了。是的！好的，听听下一个片段。你所有的姐妹都来了。看，子宫，子宫在一些兄弟姐妹到来之前不会再有空了。是的，因为你要离开了。你要出去了。我的阴道关闭了。是的，有一会儿。你的子宫，子宫。是的。
Okay, listen to this next clip. Closing time, time for you to go out to the places you want. Yes! Okay, listen to this next clip. There's all your sisters come. See that the womb, the womb is not going to be available again until some brothers and sisters come. Yeah, because you're leaving. You're going out. My vagina shut down. Yes, for a bit. Your uterus, Uterus. Yeah.
我的意思是，我想它们在分娩后都关闭了。面对现实吧。有一段时间。有一段时间。是的。这是个好主意。太甜了。太甜了。太甜了。我看了他现场演唱会讲述这个故事的完整片段，但我也看了这首歌的音乐录影带。在音乐录影带中，他们正在关闭看起来像是一家餐馆或酒吧的地方。所以你明白为什么人们把它和在酒吧联系在一起了。是的，但是，你知道，我想那是音乐录影带公司工作的某个有创意的人。他们就像，听着，我们知道这是关于
I mean, I think they both are shut down after childbirth. Let's face it. For a while. For a while. Yeah. It's a good idea. So sweet. That's so sweet. So sweet. I watched a whole clip of him telling the story during a live concert, but then I also watched their music video for this song. And in the music video, they are shutting down what looks like a restaurant or a bar. So you see why people associate it with being at a bar. Yeah, but, you know, I imagine that was some creative person that worked for the music video company. And they were like, listen, we know this is about
关闭医院的大门，还有子宫斜杠阴道。但也许这在音乐录影带中很难表现出来。对。也许我们在这里换个方向。听我说，把它变成关于酒吧。好吧，丹·威尔逊确实说过，你知道，每当你在一个乐队里，然后主唱有了孩子，
closing the doors to a hospital and also a uterus slash vagina. But maybe that is difficult to portray in a music video. Right. Maybe we switch gears here. Hear me out and make it about a bar. Well, Dan Wilson did say that, you know, whenever you're in a band and then like, the lead singer has a baby,
他们必须写一首歌关于他们的孩子，整个乐队都必须随波逐流，因为你不能告诉他们你不能写一首关于你新孩子的歌。他说，所以我想写一首歌关于它，但我试图表现得非常聪明。不幸的是，我太聪明了，没人知道这首歌是关于我的孩子的。
they have to write a song about their baby and the whole band has to go along with it because you can't tell them you can't write a song about your new baby. And he was like, so I wanted to write a song about it, but I tried to be really clever. Unfortunately, I was so clever, no one knows this song is about my baby.
啊。所以，现在我们知道了，我们觉得它太甜了。是的。好的，现在进入第三个速记事实，这个是关于末日时钟的。这一集叫《末日》。我隐约听说过末日时钟。你知道它吗，安吉拉？
Aw. So, we'll now we do and we think it's so sweet. Yes. Okay, so now moving to fastback number three, this one is all about the Doomsday Clock. This episode is called Doomsday. I had vaguely heard about the Doomsday Clock. Do you know about it, Angela?
是的，是的，当然。当然，总会有关于我们离末日时钟还有多远的公告，而且总是非常令人沮丧。李就是这么说的。就像，我们现在是有史以来离末日最近的一次。我们离末日还有90秒。是的。
Yes, yes, of course. Of course, there's always some announcement where we're at with the Doomsday Clock, and it's always really depressing. That's what Lee said. Like, we're the closest to Doomsday ever right now. We are at 90 seconds to Doomsday. Yeah.
时钟设定在离午夜还有90秒。是的。好吧。所以对于任何不知道末日的人。是的。时钟设定在离午夜还有90秒。是的。好吧。所以对于任何不知道末日时钟的人，也就是我，昨天，末日时钟的设计初衷是警告公众我们离用危险技术摧毁我们的世界还有多近。是的。
The clock is set at 90 seconds to midnight. Yeah. All right. So for anyone who doesn't know about the Doomsday. Yeah. The clock is set at 90 seconds to midnight. Yeah. All right. So for anyone who doesn't know about the Doomsday clock, aka me, yesterday, the Doomsday clock was designed to warn the public about how close we are to destroying our world with dangerous technologies. Yes.
全球灭绝。是的。它早在1947年就创建了。他们认为人类面临的最大危险来自核武器。这是因为美国和苏联当时正处于核军备竞赛中。1991年，随着冷战结束，时钟被设定在离午夜还有17分钟，这是我们离全球灭绝最远的一次。
Global extinction. Yeah. It was created all the way back in 1947. They thought that the greatest danger to humanity came from nuclear weapons. This was because the United States and Soviet Union were in their nuclear arms race. In 1991, with the end of the Cold War, the clock was set at 17 minutes to midnight, and that is the farthest we have ever been from global extinction.
我想是在1991年。关于时钟设定在哪里的决定，是由一个名为《公报》的非营利组织设定的，该组织由参与曼哈顿计划的科学家创立，你知道，那些制造第一颗原子弹的科学家，他们意识到他们不能对他们工作的后果保持沉默。所以他们组建了这个叫《公报》的组织。他们已经重置了末日时钟25次，最近一次是在2023年，当时我们把它从离午夜100秒移到了离午夜90秒。
It was in 1991, I guess. The decision as to where to set the clock, it's set by a nonprofit called the Bulletin, which was founded by scientists who worked on the Manhattan Project, you know, the scientists who built the first atomic bombs, and they realized that they could not remain a loop to the consequences of their work. So they formed this group called the bulletin. They have reset the doomsday clock 25 times, most recently in 2023 when we moved it from 100 seconds to midnight to 90 seconds to midnight.
嗯哼。末日时钟在很多音乐、电视、电影中都有出现，显然不是我听或看的东西，因为我对末日时钟相当无知。但有一首铁娘子乐队的歌叫《离午夜还有两分钟》。那是关于末日时钟的。它是《守望者》图画小说中的一个反复出现的主题。如果你愿意，你可以在Spotify上下载整个末日时钟播放列表，它们都是关于
Mm-hmm. The doomsday clock has been featured in a lot of music, television, movies, clearly not things I listen to are watched because I was pretty ignorant to the Doomsday Clock. But there is an Iron Maiden song called Two Minutes to Midnight. That is about the Doomsday Clock. It was a recurring theme in the Watchmen graphic novels. And if you want, you can download an entire Doomsday Clock playlist on Spotify and they're all songs
时钟和我们即将到来的厄运的歌曲。耶，公路旅行。好吧，你知道吗，你可以去公路旅行看看末日时钟。它位于芝加哥大学的《公报》办公室。它在大厅里。所以启动你的播放列表，在一切结束之前去和末日时钟合个影吧。这就是我所知道的。我有一个更轻松的话题
about the clock and our impending doom. Yay, road trip. Well, you know what, you can road trip to see the Doomsday Clock. It is located in the bulletin offices at the University of Chicago. It's in the lobby. So fire up your playlist and go take a picture with the Doomsday Clock before it's all over everybody. And that's what I got. I have a little something on a lighter note
来自我的数字杂物。我们拍摄这一集的那周，史蒂夫·伯吉斯给演职人员发了一封电子邮件，标题是“又是垒球时间了”。大家好，对于那些去年没和我们一起玩的人，办公室垒球队参加黄金时段垒球联盟。比赛从9月10日开始在伯班克进行。如果你想参加，请告诉我们。
from my digital clutter. The week we were filming this episode, Steve Burgess sent out an email to the casting crew, titled, It's Softball Time Again. Hi, everyone, for those who didn't play with us last year, the office softball team participates in the prime time softball league. Games take place in Burbank starting September 10th. Let us know if you'd like to play.
季后赛将在赛季末进行。这个联盟对所有在节目组工作的人及其家人开放。只要给我发邮件或短信就行。安吉拉，我记得垒球联盟。你参加了吗？我参加了一年，然后我怀孕了，然后我生了个孩子。然后去参加垒球比赛就变得非常困难。
Playoffs will be at the end of the season. This league is open to everyone who works on the show and their family members. Just email or text me. Angela, I remember the softball league. Did you play? I played one year, and then I was pregnant, and then I had a baby. And then it was very hard to get to softball games.
但我就是喜欢，喜欢公司垒球队。这就像我最喜欢的事情之一。我20多岁时曾和我的即兴表演小组一起打男女混合垒球。我们有一个垒球队。你猜怎么着？如果你找一群即兴表演者，他们有一个垒球队，会有很多段子。休息区里有太多的段子。我只记得我们有队服。是的，我们有队服。这就像乐趣的一半，去参加，演段子，你有你的队服，然后你们都去喝杯啤酒。来吧。
But I just love, love a company softball team. It is like one of my favorite things. And I used to play co-ed softball in my 20s with my improv group. We had a softball team. Guess what? If you get a bunch of improvisers and they have a softball team, there's lots of bits. So many bits. So many bits in the dugout. I just remember that we had shirts. Yeah, we had shirts. That's like half the fun is like going, doing bits, you got your shirts and you all go grab a beer after. Come on.
垒球在垒球联盟伟大的事情清单上排第四。是的，完全正确。好吧，我想我们应该休息一下，然后我们会回来。萨姆，在休息之前，你有什么打嗝的最新消息吗？我不幸的是还在打嗝。哦，天哪，萨姆。
The softball is like fourth on the list of things that are great about the softball league. Yeah, exactly. All right, well, I guess we should take a break and then we will be back. Sam, do you have a hiccups update for us before the break? I unfortunately still have the hiccups. Oh my gosh, Sam.
我知道。卡西，你对打嗝有什么主意吗？我总是屏住呼吸30秒到一分钟，但这对我没用。是的，这就是我开始的方法。我从屏住呼吸开始。萨姆，你试过了吗？不，我现在就屏住。我会一直屏到休息结束。
I know. Cassie, do you have any ideas for hiccups? I always just hold my breath for 30 seconds to a minute and that doesn't fit for me. Yeah, that's where I start. I start with holding my breath. Have you done that yet, Sam? No, I'll hold it right now. I'll hold it through the break.
好吧，天哪。我一会儿就回来。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 我们回来了。萨姆，屏住呼吸效果如何？呃，不好。哦，天哪。萨姆有史以来最顽固的打嗝。我知道。
All right, gosh. I'll be back in just a second. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ We're back. Sam, how did holding your breath work out? Uh, not good. Oh my gosh. Sam has the most stubborn hiccups ever. I know.
好吧，我们一会儿再来看看你。我们开始吧。这一集开始了。安迪像个老酒保一样闪烁着灯光。对我来说，这非常让人想起他在《午夜威胁》中的角色。嗯。透过肩膀上的斗篷，声音差不多。嗯哼。是的，丹尼说他们喜欢倾向于安迪对唱歌和表演的热爱
Alright, well we'll check in with you in a bit. Here we go. It's the start of the episode. Andy is flickering the lights like an old bartender. To me, this was very reminiscent of his character in threat level midnight. Hmm. Through the cowl over his shoulder, kind of had the same voice. Mm-hmm. Yeah, Danny said that they liked to lean into Andy's love of singing and performing
因为这确实让他与迈克尔·斯科特区分开来。是的。我的意思是，他们都喜欢表演，但方式非常不同。我确实称这个场景为，对不起，什么？嗯哼。是的，这是我的“对不起，什么？”。首先，安迪打开音响后，艾琳太兴奋了。
because that really differentiated him from Michael Scott. Yeah. I mean, they both love to perform, but very differently. I did call this scene, excuse me, what? Mm-hmm. Yeah, here's my excuse me, what? First of all, after Andy turns on the boom box, Aaron is so excited.
她就像，呜，呜，呜，那样。我心想，是的，上周发生了什么？上周在《惊吓》里，她甚至在他身边都崩溃了。看，我知道他们在最后拥抱了，我知道。但拜托。她已经到了“什么，什么”的状态了吗？我有一个答案给你。
She's like, whew, whew, whew, like that. I'm like, yeah, what happened to last week? Last week in spooked, she was wrecked at even being around him. And look, I know they hugged at the end, I know. But come on. Is she already to what, what, status? I have an answer for you.
哦，我想听听。这一集是我们今年拍摄的第三集。我们在《惊吓》之前拍摄的。我们把它乱序播放了。所以有一些故事情节可能不像你预期的那样运作，例如安迪和艾琳。是的，完全正确。好吧，谢谢你。
Oh, I want to hear it. This episode was the third episode we shot this year. We shot it before spooked. We played it out of order. So there's a few storyline things that might not work exactly as you would expect the Andy Aaron, for example. Yes, exactly. Well, thank you for that.
这也是为什么我的肚子这周又变小了。哦，对。好吧，我在这个场景中的另一个“对不起，什么？”是在13秒时，艾琳正在饮水机旁的传真机上发传真。是的。对不起。什么？
This is also why my belly is smaller this week again. Oh, right. Well, my other excuse me, what? From the scene is at 13 seconds, Aaron is faxing from a fax machine by the water cooler. Yeah. Excuse me. What?
我想另一个正在使用中。我们这里有多少传真要发？我不知道。安迪会有一个谈话头，他说每个办公室都需要一个下班传统。有些东西告诉你一天结束了。否则，你回家后，夜晚感觉就像更多的一天。这很奇怪。
I guess the other one was being used. How many faxes do we have going on here? I don't know. Andy is gonna have a talking head where he says every office needs an end of the day tradition. Something to tell you the day is over. Otherwise, you go home and the night just feels like more day. It's weird.
好吧，我们收到了很多关于这个冷开场的粉丝邮件，安吉拉，这让我开始思考，这是来自宾夕法尼亚州兰开斯特的朱莉·H，她说，为什么大家都不急着离开？为什么他们不收拾东西下班？他们不想回家吗？这对这群人来说似乎很奇怪。这是一个很好的观察。
Well, we got a lot of fan mail about this cold open Angela and this one got me thinking this is from Julie H. and Lancaster, Pennsylvania, who says, Why isn't everyone eager to leave? Why aren't they packing up for the day? Don't they want to go home? It seems odd for this bunch. That's a great observation.
是的，我的意思是，现在是五点差五分。我觉得……听着，我知道我们必须对安迪的歌声感到恼火，但我不知道。我觉得这会让我感到高兴，因为我会想，再见。是的。我的意思是，你的老板每天为你唱歌会让人厌烦。会的。如果你每天在我们录完播客时为我唱歌，如果你像，
Yeah, I mean, it's five to five. I feel like... Listen, I know that we had to be annoyed by Andy's singing, but I don't know. I feel like this would trigger me to be happy, because I'd be like, goodbye. Yeah. I mean, your boss singing to you every day would get old. It would. If you sang to me every day when we finished the podcast, if you were like,
把麦克风收起来，收拾好你的笔记本电脑，我会想，哦，天哪，好吧，我们明白了。好吧，这是我拍摄时记得的一件事，那就是《闭店时间》这首歌在我脑海里挥之不去，持续了整个星期。哦，肯定的。在我们重温这一集之后，它这周也一直在我脑海里。所以是的，我觉得这很让人抓狂。我明白为什么德怀特戴上耳机试图阻挡它。从这个角度来看，这对我来说很有意义。帕姆在这一幕中真的让我笑死了，因为感觉她就像在对我说话。我可以一遍又一遍地听一首歌。我会记住四个词。就像我很糟糕。我让我丈夫抓狂，因为他知道每一首歌的每一个词。所以当她像，回家，回家，回家，回家时。
put the microphone away, pack up your laptop, I'd be like, oh my gosh, okay, we get it. Well, here's something I remember from shooting this, which is that I had closing time stuck in my head for the rest of the week. Oh, for sure. And after we rewatched this episode, it has been in my head all this week as well. So yes, I think it is maddening. I get why Dwight puts on a set of headphones to try to block it out. It makes sense to me in that way. Pam really cracked me up in the scene because it felt like she was speaking to me. I can hear a song over and over and over. I'll like retain four words. Like I'm horrible. I drive my husband crazy because he knows every word to every song. So when she was like, and home and home and home and home.
是的，完全正确。我们还有另一个来自堪萨斯州曼哈顿的粉丝问题，来自米歇尔·W，她说我总是觉得看到某些歌曲在剧集中要花多少钱很有趣，那《闭店时间》花了多少钱？嗯哼。好吧，米歇尔，你知道，这一幕真的行不通
Yeah, exactly. We had another fan question from Michelle W. And Manhattan, Kansas, who said I always find it so interesting to see how much certain songs can cost in an episode, how much did closing time cost? Mm-hmm. Well, Michelle, you know, this scene really doesn't work
没有《闭店时间》，而且这在我们的剧本草稿中。它在剧本的每一稿中都有，我们花了25,000美元才得到这首歌。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说现在，获得歌曲版权不像当时那么贵了。我们在支付版权费方面处于行业顶峰。但我开始思考这个问题。你知道，有时这非常令人震惊，
without closing time, and this was in our table draft. It was in every draft of the script, and we paid $25,000 to get this song. Steve Burgess said nowadays, getting song rights is not as expensive as it was back then. We were kind of at the peak of the industry in terms of paying for rights. But I started thinking about this. You know, it's been very shocking sometimes, the
我们支付的金额只是为了在剧集中有一点点歌曲。但当你想到那首歌现在已经在多少流媒体设备上、在Instagram上的多少小片段中被重播了多少年，这个场景或这些歌曲出现了。这就像一笔划算的交易。这就像每播放一次几分钱。这可能是每播放一次几分钱的分数。真的吗？在补偿艺术家他们的音乐和他们对剧集的贡献方面。是的。我觉得我们赚到了。坦率地说。好吧，就像你说的，当你想到它被一遍又一遍地播放了多少次。是的。最后，这是一个来自犹他州麦肯齐的发现。
amount of money we've paid to have a little bit of a song in an episode. But when you think about the fact that that song has been replayed now for over what, how many years on how many streaming devices, on how many, like little snippets on Instagram, the scene, or these songs has appeared. It's like a bargain. It's like pennies per play. It's probably fractions of pennies per play. Really? In terms of compensating the artist for their music and for their contribution to the episode. Yeah. I think we got off-jewpe. Frankly. Well, like you said, when you think about how many times it's just played over and over and over and over. Yeah. Finally, this is a catch from Mackenzie and Utah.
当安迪开关灯时，他从灯开关旁走开，其中一个神奇地又亮了。好吧，麦肯齐，那是因为那些开关不控制灯，实际上是摄像机外有人在操作灯光板。好发现。好吧，安迪在这个冷开场中有一个挽救时刻，那就是斯坦利加入他一起唱这首歌。而莱斯利·大卫·贝克有一副好嗓子。一起唱这首歌，而莱斯利·大卫·贝克有一副好嗓子。我喜欢看到斯坦利的这一面。我喜欢看他唱歌。我的意思是，当然，斯坦利一点也不在乎这个传统。他只是很高兴他能回家。完全正确。我觉得这对于冷开场的结尾来说是一个非常好的有趣按钮，而且在角色方面也很有意义。这一集将从会议室开始。安迪和罗伯特·加利福尼亚。
When Andy is flipping the lights on and off, he steps away from the light switch and one of them turns back on magically. Well, Mackenzie, that's because those switches don't control the lights, it was actually someone off camera working a lightboard. Good catch. Well, there is one saving moment for Andy in this cold open, which is that Stanley joins him in singing the song. And Leslie David Baker has a great voice. in singing the song and Leslie David Baker has a great voice. I loved seeing this side of Stanley. I love seeing him sing. I mean, of course, Stanley doesn't care at all about this tradition. He just is happy that he gets to go home. Exactly. I thought that was such a nice fun button for the end of the cold open and makes sense character wise as well. The episode is going to start in the conference room. Andy and Robert California.
哦，太棒了。罗伯特·加利福尼亚，请不要停止说话。我就是喜欢你说的每一个字。安迪正试图进行闲聊。他正在和他聊关于《铁人厨师》。德怀特进来想在这次会议中坚持自己的立场。而罗伯特·加利福尼亚就像，你需要什么吗？基本上，他就像，你为什么在这里？是的。就像你说的，那是丹尼和编剧们的目标，你立刻看到，德怀特只是拼命想要认可
Oh, it's so good. Robert California, please don't stop talking. I just love every single word you say. And Andy's trying to make small talk. He's chatting with him about the iron chef. Dwight comes in wanting to assert himself into this meeting. And Robert California's like, did you need something? Basically, he's like, why are you here? Yeah. And like what you said, that was a goal of Danny and the writers immediately you see, Dwight just desperately wanting validation
而且这将在整集中上演。罗伯特·加利福尼亚将向安迪解释他们有这种票务软件，能够追踪所犯的错误，而且最近确实有很多错误。丹尼说编剧们必须学习票务软件，这在当时是非常新的，而且看起来有点奇怪，你可以追踪人们在电脑上做的事情。他说现在这很常见。追踪人们在电脑上做的事情。他说现在这很常见。他说他很确定贾斯汀·斯皮策有一个家庭成员在工作中使用过票务软件
and it's gonna play out throughout the whole episode. Robert California is going to explain to Andy that they have this ticketing software that is able to Kind of track mistakes that are made and that there have been quite a lot of mistakes lately Danny said that the writers had to educate themselves on ticketing software Which at the time was very new and it seemed kind of weird that you could Track things that people were doing on their computer. He said it's very commonplace now track things that people were doing on their computer. He said it's very commonplace now. He said he's pretty sure Justin Spitzer had a family member who had used ticketing software
所以他们一直向他们询问细节。太棒了。丹尼说这种情况经常发生，因为大多数编剧对正常办公室的实际运作知之甚少。所以他们总是不得不问某人的朋友、姐妹或家庭成员之类的。这太真实了。我的意思是，这就是格雷格总是来找你和我，安吉拉，因为作为演员，我们曾在企业美国广泛工作过。是的。好吧，罗伯特指出了几个会计错误。安迪说，好吧，那是“叮当”和“叮当”，都是凯文。嗯哼。是的。然后罗伯特在这里有一个小演讲，是“叮当”和“叮当”，都是凯文。嗯哼，是的。然后罗伯特在这里有一个小演讲，是我整个
in their job and so they kept hitting them up for details. Awesome. Danny said that was off in the case because most of the writers had very little knowledge about the actual workings of a normal office. So they'd always have to ask someone's friend or sister or family member or whatever. And that's so true. I mean, that's how Greg were always coming to you and I, Angela, because as cast members, we had worked extensively in corporate America. Yeah. Well, Robert points out a few accounting errors. And Andy says, well, that's tweedledie and tweedledum, which are both Kevin. Mm-hmm. Yeah. And then Robert has a little speech here that's Tweedle D and Tweedle Dumb, which are both Kevin. Mm-hmm, yeah. And then Robert has a little speech here that's one of my favorites in the whole entire
剧集中最喜欢的演讲之一。我必须读一下。他基本上对安迪说，结束错误。然后他说，当我下周回来，这份打印件显示没有错误时，那我们就可以整天谈论名字了。我们最喜欢的名字，愚蠢的虚构名字，我们的正常名字，用愚蠢的声音说出来。那不是很好吗？
episode. I have to read it. He basically says to Andy, end the mistakes. And then he says, when I come back next week and this printout shows me no mistakes, then we can talk about names all day. Our favorite names, silly made up names, our normal names, said in a silly voice. Wouldn't that be nice?
我也喜欢那个。我想看那段对话。我想看他下周回来，真的让安迪用那些名字和绰号。嗯哼。好吧，吉姆要跳进达里尔的办公室，邀请他和贾斯汀去和他与帕姆进行双重约会，去参加轮滑德比。
I love that too. I want to see that conversation. I want to see him come back next week and really just let Andy go with the names and the nicknames. Mm-hmm. Well, Jim is going to bounce into Daryl's office and invite him and Justine to go on a double date with him and Pam to the roller derby.
我知道轮滑德比，我太好奇了。我当时想，好吧。好吧，那是因为NBA停摆。我想他们正在寻找做一些新东西。我们收到了一个来自宾夕法尼亚州威尔克斯-巴里的粉丝问题，来自莎拉·S。嗨，莎拉。莎拉说，我一直在等这一集，因为吉姆和达里尔谈论去看轮滑德比的那一幕。
I know roller derby, I was so curious. I was like, okay. Well that's because of the NBA lockout. They're looking to do some new stuff, I guess. We got a fan question from Sarah S and Wilkesbury, Pennsylvania. Hi Sarah. Sarah says, I have been waiting for this episode to come up because of this scene when Jim Talks to Darryl about going to see Roller Derby.
好吧，他们绝对可以在斯克兰顿附近看到一些轮滑德比。我是威尔克斯-巴里斯克兰顿轮滑德比联盟的一员，在这一集播出时，我们的团队就已经存在并会在威尔克斯-巴里滑冰了。现在我们在离特里·斯坦纳不远的地方练习和比赛，当你来斯克兰顿旅游时，非常欢迎你随时过来。签名莎拉，然后她的轮滑德比名字是亚历山大·斯兰米尔顿。斯兰米尔顿！莎拉，我很想去，我很想带上我的溜冰鞋。我可以只绕一圈吗
Well, they absolutely can see some Roller Derby near Scranton. I am part of the Wilkesbury Scranton Roller Derby League and at the time that this episode aired, our team would have existed and been skating in Wilkesbury. Now we practice and play in music right down the road from Terry Steiner, and you are more than welcome to drop in whenever you come for your scrant and tour. Signed Sarah, and then her roller derby name is Alexander Slamilton. Slamilton! Sarah, I would love to come, and I'd love to bring my skates. Can I just go one lap
就像我没有碰撞。好吧，听着，在这一幕中我有一个发现。是达里尔的杯子。我不知道你有没有注意到，上面写着C和C，康德林和公司。不，那代表什么？听听这个杯子代表什么。它代表一家公司。他们是一家全方位的广告和公共关系公司。他们所做的是在电视上制作和投放广告，
around like I don't I don't with no bumps. All right, listen, in the scene I have a catch. It's Darryl's mug. I don't know if you noticed it, but it says C and C, Condrin and company. No, what does that stand for? Listen to what this mug represents. It represents a company. They are a full service advertising and public relations firm. And what they do is they produce and place advertising on TV,
广播广告牌、印刷、互联网和病毒式媒体。他们实际上把他们自己公司的杯子放在了我们的电视节目中，我只需要给一个慢动作鼓掌。有胆量？有胆量。讨厌。干得好，伙计们。
radio billboards, print, internet, and viral media. They literally placed their own mug for their own company on our TV show, which I just need to give a slow clap. Ballsy? Ballsy. Nasty. Real good job, guys.
干得好。玩得好。所以在下一幕中，德怀特走进安迪的办公室告诉他，他有一个解决他们错误问题的可能方案，一个让每个人对彼此的工作负责的系统。然后，女士，德怀特有一个巨大的手风琴式文件夹，带有一根绳子，像锁一样。我必须知道这根绳子的事情是否是剧本写的，因为你知道雷恩喜欢道具。他喜欢道具。
Well done. Well played. So in the next scene, Dwight has gone into Andy's office to tell him he has a possible solution to their mistakes problem, a system that holds everyone responsible for each other's work. And then, lady, Dwight has this huge accordion like folder with a string, like lock. I had to know if this string business was scripted because you know, rain loves a prop. He loves a prop.
所以我当时想，雷恩和菲尔·谢是什么，剧本里有什么。这是它写的。德怀特站在安迪的桌子前，拿着一个用绳子封住的手风琴文件夹。他非常兴奋。然后当安迪似乎接受他的想法时，拍摄草稿是这样写的。德怀特，非常兴奋，试图快速解开他信封上的绳子。它进行得不够快。
So it was like, I was like, what was rain and fill Shay and what was in the script? This is what it says. Dwight stands in front of Andy's desk holding an accordion file closed with the string. He is very excited. And then when Andy seems receptive to his idea, here's what the shooting draft said. Dwight, extremely excited, tries to quickly undo the string ties on his envelope. It's not going fast enough.
哦，天哪，那是剧本写的。是的，奇怪的绳子工作是剧本写的。这是我整集中最喜欢的细节之一。我当时想，多么棒的小细节。是的，那很棒。我还需要知道珍娜，安迪那句“你是我想永远抓住的傻瓜”是剧本写的，还是埃德在那一刻即兴发挥的。它不仅是剧本写的，而且还有一句后续台词没有出现在剧集中，那就是，“伙计，别这样，你是我想永远抓住的傻瓜。”
Oh my gosh, that was scripted. Yes, the weird string work is scripted. It's one of my favorite details of this whole episode. I was like, what a great little detail. Yeah, that's pretty great. I also needed to know Jenna if Andy's line of, you're the doose I never want to drop, was scripted or if Ed was improvising in this moment. Not only was it scripted, but it had a follow-up line that didn't make it in the episode, which was, dude, don't even, you're the doose I never want to drop.
如果必须的话，我会从山顶上喊出来。这让我笑死了。我非常喜欢每周阅读我们的拍摄草稿。我读的时候会大声笑出来。它们太棒了。我们的编剧简直太棒了，坦率地说。好吧，现在盖博要接近托比
I'll scream that from the mountain tops if I have to. Just cracked me up. I so enjoy reading our shooting drafts every week. I laugh out loud reading them. They're so good. Our writers were just the absolute s**t quite frankly. Well, now Gabe is going to approach Toby writers were just the absolute sh** quite frankly. Well, now Gabe is gonna approach Toby
因为他想和人力资源部开始一些关于他和瓦尔新关系的文书工作。哦，好吧。他不是在正式约会，但对她有吸引力。他甚至不知道她的姓。他不知道，但她今晚会尖叫出来的。托比说她会尖叫出她自己的名字。
because he would like to start some paperwork with HR about his new relationship with Val. Oh, okay. He is not technically dating, but feels an attraction for. He doesn't even know her last name. He doesn't, but she'll be screaming it tonight. Toby says she's gonna be screaming her own name.
这是一句非常有趣的台词。他给了我们像，嘿，小心点。是的。接下来，将有一个会议室会议，我有很多明迪破功的报道。我有一个雷恩破功。哦，好吧。让我们休息一下，我们会回来，和在这一幕中笑得前仰后合的每个人一起。
It was a very funny line. He gave us like, hey, watch it. Yeah. Up next, there's gonna be a conference room meeting, and I have a lot of Mindy breaking to report on. I have a rain break. Oh, all right. Let's take a break, and we'll be back with everyone who is cracking up in the scene.
好吧，我们回来了，在我们去这个会议室会议之前，萨姆。我们怎么样了？我还在打嗝。你现在在打我吗？不，我是认真的。我还在打嗝，而且很严重。你以前有过这么严重的打嗝吗？是的，我想我是……这对你来说很常见吗？
All right, we're back before we go to this conference room meeting Sam. How are we doing? I still have the hiccups. You're hitting me right now. No, I'm serious. I still have them and they're bad. Have you ever had them this bad before? Yeah, I guess I'm... Is this common for you?
是的，是的。你怎么办？我只是顺其自然。我只是顺其自然。我的意思是，萨姆，我们从今天早上9点半就开始和你说话了。所以你现在已经打了一个小时我们知道的嗝了。就像你以前打过多久？就像，是一整个早上吗？
Yes, yes it is. What do you do? I just ride it out. I just ride it out. I mean, Sam, we've been talking to you since 9.30 this morning. So you've had them now an hour for that we know of. Like how long have you had them before? Like, has it been all morning?
是的，从我今天早上起床开始。哇，萨姆，那是史诗级的打嗝。我知道。是的。你认为进行体力锻炼会帮你摆脱打嗝吗？就像如果你去健身房，那是一件美妙的事情。这一集之后我会知道的。
Yeah, since I got up this morning. Wow, Sam, that's epic hiccup. I know. Yep. Do you think that exerting yourself physically would help you get rid of the hiccups? Like if you went to the gym and it's a wonderful thing. I'll find out after this episode.
好的。哦，伙计。如果这一集结束时它们还没好，我需要你在它们消失时给我发短信。我会的，我会的。好的，我需要那个结局。我会的。对我来说也是。
Okay. Oh, buddy. If they are over by the end of this episode, I'm gonna need you to text me when they are gone. I will, I will. Okay, I'm gonna need that closure for you. I will. And for me.
是的。好吧，安吉拉，让我们进入这个会议室会议。我们有什么？好吧，安迪要从赞美每个人开始。他就像，嘿，你们做得太棒了，但你们也真的很草率。他要让德怀特介绍问责助推器。但我希望每个人都去七分钟，因为明迪在七分钟时破功了。我们收到了来自佛罗里达州坦帕市鲁查玛的粉丝发现，
Yeah. All right, Angela, let's get into this conference room meeting. What do we got? Well, Andy's going to start off by complimenting everyone. He's like, hey, you're doing amazing, but you're also being really sloppy. And he's going to let Dwight introduce the accountability booster. But I want everyone to go to seven minutes because Mindy is breaking at seven minutes. We had a fan catch from Ruchama in Tampa, Florida,
她说，在七分零八秒，安迪说“嗨，伙计们”后，凯利是唯一一个回应“嗨”的人。你可以看到，雷恩作为德怀特直视镜头，他有点像要破功一样在笑。你们也注意到了吗，因为我已经重播了五次，这对我来说太搞笑了？是的，一旦你指出来，我就注意到了。
who said, at seven minutes and eight seconds, Kelly is the only one to respond high back to Andy after he says hi guys. And you can see, Rayne as white look right at the camera, and he's kind of smiling like he's going to break. Did you guys notice it, too, because I've replayed it five times and it's so funny to me? Yes, once you pointed it out, I did.
我起初没有注意到这一点，但安吉拉，就像你说的，明迪一坐下，她就已经在笑了。我看了剧本，她回应安迪的“嗨”是一个即兴表演，显然让雷恩笑了。而且他，我想他看着镜头就像，我们要继续吗？因为明迪显然破功了，发生了什么事。这就是我认为正在发生的事情。我想看戴夫·罗杰斯拥有的扩展镜头，因为在那一幕的开头发生了一些事情，就像你说的。
I did not notice this at first, but Angela, like you said, the minute Mindy sits down, she's already laughing. I looked at the script, her saying hi back to Andy is an improvisation that clearly made rain laugh. And he, I think he's looking at camera like, are we going to keep going? Because Mindy is clearly breaking and what's going on. That's what I think is happening. I wanted to see like the extended footage of Dave Rogers had it because something happened at the top of that scene, like you said.
而且它延续到了开始时的实际场景中。我立刻注意到雷恩直视镜头。然后它立刻切到明迪、BJ和布莱恩，他们看起来都快要崩溃了。明迪是最明显的。然后你看到我的脸的一侧，我有一个奇怪的半笑。所以场景之间发生了一些事情。
And it was carrying into the actual scene when it started. I clocked rain looking right camera right away. And then immediately it cuts to Mindy and BJ and Brian and they all look like they're about to lose it. Mindy is just the most obvious. And then you see the side of my face and I've got a weird kind of half smile. So something was happening between scenes.
我想我们可能在演一个段子，在必须开始工作之前没有足够的停机时间。我们有残留的笑声。是的，这是我的猜测。德怀特要和大家分享问责助推器将记录每个人犯错的每一次。你有基本上五个错误，五个好球，
I think we were probably doing a bit and there wasn't enough downtime before we had to start work. And we had like residual laughing going on. Yeah. That's my guess. Dwight is going to share with everyone that the accountability booster is going to register every time someone makes mistake. And you have basically five mistakes, five strikes,
等于一个本垒打，一个本垒打意味着你出局了。是的，发生的事情是这个程序，我想，会自动发送给罗伯特·加利福尼亚所有人写的关于他的刻薄电子邮件，叫他的名字，然后每个人都会被解雇。这是他们的，你知道，基本上是在隐喻地炸毁办公室。不仅是刻薄的电子邮件，它还会发送去年的顾问报告，其中建议关闭这个分公司。哦，是的，没错。
equals a home run, one home run means you're out. Yes, and what happens is this program, I guess, is going to automatically send Robert California all of the snarky emails that people have written about him, calling him names, and then everyone will be fired. This is their, you know, it's blowing up the office, basically metaphorically. Not only the snarky emails, but it's going to send them the consultant report from last year where it was recommended that this branch be shut down. Oh, yeah, that's right.
我忘了那部分。罗伯特·加利福尼亚怎么从来没看到那个。我不知道，但他们一直对他隐瞒。我希望你们都知道，当德怀特列出每个人的刻薄电子邮件时，他说，“他吃酸奶就像在惩罚它让他失望一样，凯利。”而明迪，作为凯利说，“那其实没那么糟糕。”然后德怀特说，“PS，我们应该杀了他。”明迪完全崩溃了。
I forgot that part. How Robert, California never saw that. I don't know, but they've been hiding it from him. I want you guys all to know, when Dwight is listing everyone's snarky emails and he says, he eats yogurt like he's punishing it for disappointing him, Kelly. And Mindy, as Kelly says, that's not that bad, actually. Then Dwight says, PS, we should kill him. Mindy totally loses it.
她捂住脸，弯下腰。就是那几分钟。她确实。她完全做到了。然后吉姆实际上要叫住德怀特说，这是一个末日装置。吉姆是第一个称它为末日装置的人。德怀特要说，不，这是一个问责助推器。
She covers her face and doubles over. That's it in minutes. She does. She totally does. And then Jim is actually going to call Dwight out and say, this is a Doomsday device. And Jim is the first person to call it a Doomsday device. And Dwight is going to say, no, it's an accountability booster.
但算了吧。每个人都锁定了末日，这就是现在每个人称呼它的方式。安迪开始怀疑了。他就像，我不知道，这是一个好主意吗？德怀特向他保证，这会让每个人进步，这将是一件好事。斯坦利要说，这个末日装置
But forget it. Everyone has locked in to Doomsday, and this is now what everyone's calling it. Andy is starting to get skeptical. He's like, I don't know, is this a good idea? And Dwight assures him that this is gonna make everyone improve, it's gonna be a good thing. Stanley's gonna say, this Doomsday device
听起来像是一种恐吓策略。女士，斯坦利的那一刻还有更多内容。太搞笑了，我想让你听听。至少不超过四个。这个末日装置。听起来像是一种恐吓策略。又是Y2K。哦，我当时全神贯注于Y2K漏洞。
sounds like a scare tactic. Lady, there was so much more to the Stanley moment. It's so funny, I want you to hear it. At least no more than four. This doomsday device. Sounds like a scare tactic to me. Y2K all over again. Oh, I was all about the Y2K bug.
我不得不更新我的电脑，扔掉我的微波炉，取消我的机票，卖掉我的股票，在地下室过新年，脸上戴着防毒面具。我甚至穿着尿布。有人说Y2K会搞定厕所。哦，天哪。哦，天哪，那带回了太多的回忆。
Pates, I'm got to update my PCs throughout my microwave, cancel my playing ticket, so long my stops, spent new years even my basement with a gas mask on my face. I was even wearing a diaper. Someone said Y2K would get the toilets. Oh my God. Oh my God, that's bringing back so many memories.
帕特斯，我得升级我的电脑，把微波炉扔了，取消我的机票，停止我的所有活动，我在地下室戴着防毒面具度过了除夕夜。我甚至还穿了尿布。有人说千年虫问题会毁掉厕所。天哪。天哪，这勾起了我太多的回忆。
Angela, I remember the anxiety about Y2K. And then nothing happened. And then nothing happened. We're all here, guys. We're okay, but Stanley really bought into it. And now there's a doomsday device, and he is not having it. Well, Oscar is skeptical.
安吉拉，我还记得对千年虫问题的焦虑。结果什么都没发生。结果什么都没发生。伙计们，我们都还在这儿。我们没事，但斯坦利真的信以为真了。现在有了个末日装置，他可受不了。嗯，奥斯卡对此持怀疑态度。
He's going to need to test it. He is going to purposely make a mistake to see what happens. And guess what? It worked. Now they have their first mistake. There's only four left. Yeah, there would have been a Pam and Jim runner here where Pam is like, you know what?
他需要测试一下。他会故意犯个错来看看会发生什么。你猜怎么着？成功了。现在他们有了第一个错误。只剩下四个了。是的，这里本来会有一个帕姆和吉姆的支线，帕姆会说，你知道吗？
This device might be real, and they have a whole squabble about it. And I want you to hear it. It's very funny. This could be real. Dwight's pretty handy with computers. He fixed my laptop once. Okay, he didn't fix it. The brightness level was all the way down. You couldn't fix it. I wasn't was all the way down. You couldn't fix it. I wasn't here that day. Yes, you were. No.
这个装置可能是真的，他们为此吵了一架。我想让你听听。非常有趣。这可能是真的。德怀特对电脑很在行。他曾经修好过我的笔记本电脑。好吧，他没修好。亮度调到了最低。你没法修好它。我那天不在。不，你在。没有。
Okay, well, we'll talk about it later. Straussburg, I had a meeting in Straussburg and I dropped you off beforehand. I was wearing a tan shirt with stripes. I don't think so, babe. Okay, this is crazy. That's so real. That is so real. That is so real couple stuff.
好吧，我们以后再谈。斯特劳斯堡，我在斯特劳斯堡有个会议，我提前把你放下了。我当时穿着一件棕褐色的条纹衬衫。我不这么认为，宝贝。好吧，这太疯狂了。这太真实了。这真是太真实了，情侣之间才会有的事。
I know, I know. We had a fan catch from Christina B. in South Carolina who said, first off, I will have to start by saying this is my favorite episode of the office. Then Christina said, continuity catch. When everyone is questioning the doomsday device, Oscar says he will test it by sending an order down to shipping before payment has been received. However, on Dwight's computer screen,
我知道，我知道。我们收到了来自南卡罗来纳州克里斯蒂娜·B的粉丝投稿，她说，首先，我得先说这是我最喜欢的《办公室》剧集。然后克里斯蒂娜说，连续性捕捉。当每个人都在质疑末日装置时，奥斯卡说他要通过在收到付款前向运输部门发送订单来测试它。然而，在德怀特的电脑屏幕上，
it says the mistake is, quote, late delivery. But that's not the mistake that Oscar made. There's actually a mistake in the Doomsday device. Mm. And Christo was asking if we know why Oscar's mistake was categorized this way. Christo, I looked in the script. There was nothing scripted for Dwight's screen to say. So I don't know why it was there, but it is true.
上面写着错误是，引用，“延迟交付”。但那不是奥斯卡犯的错误。末日装置里其实有个错误。嗯。克里斯托问我们是否知道为什么奥斯卡的错误被这样归类。克里斯托，我查了剧本。德怀特的屏幕上没有任何剧本要求显示的内容。所以我不知道为什么会有那个，但这是真的。
It's not a late delivery. And now that I've seen it, I can't unsee it and it bothers me too. Such a good catch. I am telling you, office fans are on it. They are on it. Listen, I think it's because people have watched it so many times. You're not gonna get away with tiny details that are wrong anymore. Maybe in the first viewing, but not upon multiple viewings.
那不是延迟交付。现在我看到了，我就没法假装没看见，这也困扰着我。真是个好发现。我跟你说，办公室的粉丝们真的很敏锐。他们真的很敏锐。听着，我认为这是因为人们看了太多遍了。你再也无法用微小的错误细节蒙混过关了。也许第一遍看不出来，但多看几遍就不行了。
Nope. Another storyline that's been playing out is the fact that Gabe, as we've talked about, is Smitten with Val. Val had come upstairs to tell Darryl you've got to come to the safety meeting. Gabe, of course, has an awkward, tries to flirt moment with her and now Gabe has gone down to the warehouse to attend the safety meeting. But really, he's just making jokes at Darryl's expense because he thinks that Val likes a good put down. That's all he knows about her, so he's going to milk it. Yeah.
没错。另一个一直在上演的故事情节是，正如我们所讨论的，盖博迷上了瓦尔。瓦尔上楼告诉达里尔你得来参加安全会议。盖博当然表现得很尴尬，试图和她调情，现在盖博已经下到仓库去参加安全会议了。但实际上，他只是在拿达里尔开玩笑，因为他认为瓦尔喜欢被损。这就是他对她的全部了解，所以他打算利用这一点。是的。
Yeah. Has anyone from corporate ever attended a warehouse safety meeting? I don't know. I don't think so. Back up in the bullpen, it's three strikes. Aaron is keeping track by putting big pieces of red tape on the front of the reception desk. Good job, Aaron.
是的。公司里有人参加过仓库安全会议吗？我不知道。我不这么认为。回到办公区，已经是三振出局了。艾琳通过在接待台前贴上大块红胶带记录着。干得好，艾琳。
This is when we're going to find out that they're not letting Kevin do any real work. They've told him that a really big client needs to know the story of how paper gets made. That's how they're keeping him occupied. The rest of the folks in the office are trying to figure out what white's password might be so that they can cancel the Doomsday device. Yeah. We had a fan catch from Charlotte D in the UK. She said all of the men in the scene are wearing shades of blue and the women are all wearing purple. It's true. And then Dwight appears in his usual sort of muted mustard yellow.
这时我们发现他们没让凯文做任何真正的工作。他们告诉他，一个非常大的客户需要了解纸张是如何制造的故事。这就是他们让他忙碌的方式。办公室里的其他人正试图弄清楚德怀特的密码可能是什么，以便他们可以取消末日装置。是的。我们收到了来自英国夏洛特·D的粉丝投稿。她说场景里的所有男人都穿着深浅不一的蓝色衣服，而女人们都穿着紫色。这是真的。然后德怀特穿着他通常那种柔和的芥末黄出现了。
And she wondered if this was on purpose to help Dwight stand out from the others and show how he is separate from the group. It certainly did. She said it looked like a conscious choice to make the office seem united against Dwight. Like they were united in their color palette. united against Dwight. Like they were united in their color palette. Mm-hmm. Charlotte, I love the idea that this was on purpose. I'm guessing it was probably an accident, but it works. It's a great teblow. Well Gabe is going to try to flex in front of Val by asking Darryl to go get everyone coffee with a crisp $100 bill, but Darryl flips it because he invites Val to go with him. So now Gabe is just at the warehouse with the fellas.
她想知道这是否是故意的，为了帮助德怀特从其他人中脱颖而出，并展示他如何与群体分离。确实如此。她说这看起来是一个有意识的选择，让办公室看起来团结一致对抗德怀特。就像他们在色调上是统一的。团结一致对抗德怀特。就像他们在色调上是统一的。嗯哼。夏洛特，我喜欢这是故意的这个想法。我猜这可能是一个意外，但效果很好。这是一个很棒的群像。好吧，盖博试图在瓦尔面前炫耀，让达里尔用一张崭新的100美元钞票去给大家买咖啡，但达里尔反转了局面，因为他邀请瓦尔和他一起去。所以现在盖博只是和伙计们待在仓库里。
Yes, and then Angela is checking it on Oscar. She's like, did you take care of our client, Reinhart and Wolf? That's your line, Angela. I say you sent the late notice to Reinhart and Wolf, right? Danny Chun said that those names were a nod to his friend's Brook Reinhardt and Steve Wolf, and he sneaked him in the episode. Aww. But things aren't good for Reinhardt and Wolf because Oscar messed up.
是的，然后安吉拉在检查奥斯卡。她说，你处理好我们的客户莱因哈特和沃尔夫了吗？那是你的台词，安吉拉。我说你给莱因哈特和沃尔夫发了逾期通知，对吧？丹尼·春说这些名字是对他朋友布鲁克·莱因哈特和史蒂夫·沃尔夫的致敬，他把他们塞进了这一集。噢。但莱因哈特和沃尔夫的情况不太好，因为奥斯卡搞砸了。
Yes, Angela begged him to use a calculator, but no, Oscar doesn't trust a calculator. In stressful situations, he relies on his noggin, and he made a mistake. So it's five strikes, it's a home run, you're out. And everyone's in total panic. Doomsday device has been activated. They find out at five o'clock, it's gonna send out all the emails and the consultant report, everything.
是的，安吉拉求他用计算器，但没有，奥斯卡不相信计算器。在压力大的情况下，他依赖自己的脑袋，结果他犯了个错。所以是五振出局，全垒打，你出局了。每个人都陷入了极度的恐慌。末日装置已经被激活了。他们在五点钟发现，它会发送所有的电子邮件和顾问报告，所有的一切。
In less Dwight enters in his password. And so everyone's like, like well then enter in your password No, he says they don't deserve it and he leaves. He's like goodbye. I did have another Mindy breaking catch Which part during the screaming or otherwise because she's smiling a little bit at the end of this That's a good point if you go to 14, 14 seconds right after Kevin says the man tree puts its penis, it cuts to an overshoulder shot and you see her shoulders shaking. We all thought that line was really funny. I remember doing that one. So Dwight has left. He's bailed and now they're trying to figure out how do we
除非德怀特输入他的密码。所以每个人都说，好吧，那输入你的密码。不，他说他们不配，然后他就走了。他说再见。我还有一个明迪笑场的发现。哪一部分？在尖叫期间还是其他时候？因为她在这一集的结尾笑了一点点。说得好。如果你去到14分14秒，就在凯文说“人树长出了它的阴茎”之后，镜头切到了过肩镜头，你可以看到她的肩膀在颤抖。我们都觉得那句台词真的很有趣。我记得拍那一段的时候。所以德怀特离开了。他溜了，现在他们正试图弄清楚我们该如何
coax this code out of him. How do we get him to stop this? It's going to involve Andy Pam, Aaron, and Kevin going to shrewt farms. They come upon him and he is digging a giant hole. It turns out it's a grave for a horse. How did you get through that? I would have laughed so hard the minute he says, and if you hit something is probably another horse. If you hit another horse, you've dug too far.
哄骗他交出密码。我们怎么让他停止这个？这需要安迪、帕姆、艾琳和凯文去施鲁特农场。他们遇到他时，他正在挖一个巨大的洞。结果那是给马挖的坟墓。你是怎么坚持下来的？他一说“如果你撞到了什么东西，那可能是另一匹马。如果你撞到了另一匹马，说明你挖得太深了”，我肯定会笑得不行。
Yeah, exactly. Well, lady, we did not get through the scene. It was so funny. I had instant memories of it when I watched it again, because there were also ults. In addition to getting what you saw on the screen, we also had to shoot this. Pam says, oh, no, your horse died.
是的，没错。好吧，女士，我们没能顺利拍完那个场景。太搞笑了。当我再次观看时，我立刻有了回忆，因为还有删减片段。除了你在屏幕上看到的，我们还必须拍这个。帕姆说，噢，不，你的马死了。
And Dwight said, no. If you wait for the horse to die, the corpse is sitting out for days for the other animals to see. Once the animals know about death, it's all over. We couldn't get through that. And another one was when Pam said, oh no, your horse died, Dwight said, no, I'm trying to trap some horse graverobbers.
德怀特说，不。如果你等马死了，尸体放几天让其他动物看到。一旦动物知道了死亡，一切就完了。我们没法拍完那一段。还有一段是帕姆说，噢，不，你的马死了，德怀特说，不，我正在试图诱捕一些马匹盗墓贼。
So he was digging trap some horse grave robbers. So he was digging a fake horse grave as a trap. Oh my goodness. Well, I'll tell you guys, we shot this out at Disney Ranch and we actually shot this the Friday before we shot Garden Party and Steve Burgess says the reason the camera never really pans very far to the left of Dwight's farmhouse is because they had already started setting up the tent for Garden Party, and we
所以他正在挖诱捕马匹盗墓贼的陷阱。所以他正在挖一个假的马坟墓作为陷阱。天哪。好吧，我告诉你们，我们是在迪士尼牧场拍摄的，我们实际上是在拍摄《花园派对》之前的那个周五拍的。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，摄像机从来没有向德怀特农舍的左侧平移太远的原因是，他们已经开始为《花园派对》搭建帐篷了，我们
had to keep it out of frame. We had a very limited like shooting area because we were already in prep. Well, while you guys are all at Shrute Farms trying to talk Dwight into giving you the passcode, Jim has been sent on assignment to keep Robert California busy and not looking at his phone. So he doesn't notice if he gets emails, right, at five o'clock. And the task is go play squash with Robert California. Aaron is like he's somewhere either eating squash or playing squash. So Jim is on the case. There was actually a deleted Jim talking head where he shares how much he knows about squash and i want you to hear it i have never played squash
必须把它挡在画面之外。我们的拍摄区域非常有限，因为我们已经在准备了。好吧，当你们都在施鲁特农场试图说服德怀特给你们密码时，吉姆被派去执行任务，让罗伯特·加利福尼亚忙起来，不要看他的手机。这样他就不会注意到五点钟是否收到了邮件，对吧？任务是去和罗伯特·加利福尼亚打壁球。艾琳说他要么在吃壁球，要么在打壁球。所以吉姆接手了这个案子。实际上有一个被删减的吉姆的采访镜头，他分享了他对壁球的了解，我想让你听听。我从来没打过壁球
but i've seen it in countless a days movies and it seems like the most common stake is that you serve too hard to yourself right in the squash balls so so i don't do that i think i'll be alright that's a very funny talking head that's all he knows about squash and when he arrives he's actually ripping the tag off his racket. He's clearly never played, although he tells Robert California like, Hey, I play all the time. It starts a very funny runner between the two of them.
但我看过无数次电影，似乎最常见的错误就是你发球太用力，直接打到自己身上，对吧？所以我不会那样做，我想我会没事的。那是一个非常有趣的采访镜头。这就是他对壁球的全部了解，当他到达时，他实际上正在撕掉球拍上的标签。他显然从来没打过，尽管他告诉罗伯特·加利福尼亚说，嘿，我经常打。这在他们两人之间引发了一个非常有趣的支线。
And lady, I have a little digital clutter to share here. Oh, yeah? Yeah. You and I did not work on the squash shoot days. Okay. Guess what we were doing. I have no idea. Okay.
女士，我这里有个小小的数字杂物要分享。噢，是吗？是的。你和我没有在壁球拍摄日工作。好吧。猜猜我们在做什么。我不知道。好吧。
You emailed me, hey lady, if I'm not totally wrecked by shooting at Shrute Farms, I'll come over tomorrow on our day off and grab the bassinet from you. I can't wait to see you, and maybe I can even see Isabel. Yes! That's right. You let me borrow this beautiful white wicker bassinet. Oh, I remember that. I was so happy that someone else could use it because it was such a beautiful gift that I got when Isabel was born. Our family members went in together and bought us this beautiful white wicker bassinet. The kind that, you
你给我发了封邮件，嘿女士，如果我在施鲁特农场拍摄没被彻底累垮的话，我明天休息日会过去从你那儿拿走摇篮。我迫不及待想见到你，也许我甚至能见到伊莎贝尔。是的！没错。你借给我这个漂亮的白色柳条摇篮。噢，我记得那个。我很高兴有人能用它，因为它是我在伊莎贝尔出生时收到的非常漂亮的礼物。我们的家人凑钱给我们买了这漂亮的白色柳条摇篮。那种，你
know, you can, it has handles and you can take it off or you can put it on the base and kind of roll it through the house. I remember that we kept it up in our kitchen. I know it made me so happy. So back at troop farms, everyone has helped Dwight dig his horse grave and they're tired and Pam asked if they can come inside for a little water. She's going to talk about how, oh, I forgot how pretty it was in here. It's so lovely.
知道，它有把手，你可以把它拿下来，或者你可以把它放在底座上，在房子里推着走。我记得我们把它放在厨房里。我知道，这让我很高兴。回到施鲁特农场，每个人都帮德怀特挖了他的马坟墓，他们累了，帕姆问他们能不能进去喝点水。她会说，噢，我忘了这里有多漂亮了。真是太可爱了。
And they're gonna sit down. He's gonna serve them some cabbage pie. And they're having this pie and making small talk. And I don't know if you noticed, but over Dwight's shoulder, there's a bit where Kevin comes out of the kitchen and he's holding a frying pan. How can you not notice that Kevin is going to pretend to maybe whack Dwight with a frying pan?
他们会坐下来。他会给他们端上一些卷心菜派。他们吃着派，闲聊着。我不知道你有没有注意到，在德怀特的肩膀上方，有个片段是凯文从厨房出来，手里拿着一个平底锅。你怎么可能没注意到凯文假装可能要用平底锅敲德怀特呢？
Danny said that the first frying pan they gave to Kevin was the largest frying pan anyone had ever seen. He said it was like two feet in diameter. And that he and Troy were like no, no, no, just a normal frying pan. And they had to switch it out. I have two things to share about this. First of all, I wanted to see what it said in the shooting draft. It said this. Kevin creeps in from off screen. He's got a big cast iron skill in his hands. He lifts it over Dwight's head to smash him. Pam shakes her head. No. Kevin sets the skillet down and rejoins the table.
丹尼说，他们给凯文的第一个平底锅是任何人见过的最大的平底锅。他说直径大概有两英尺。他和特洛伊说，不，不，不，要一个普通的平底锅。他们不得不把它换掉。关于这个我有两件事要分享。首先，我想看看拍摄草稿里是怎么写的。上面写着：凯文从画面外悄悄走进来。他手里拿着一个大铸铁煎锅。他把它举过德怀特的头顶想要砸他。帕姆摇了摇头。不。凯文放下煎锅，重新回到桌边。
Well, this got me very curious about why Kevin would do this, why is he acting so odd? And I found more nuggets in the shooting draft. You might have noticed that Kevin doesn't say a single word while he's at troop farms. In fact, you'll notice he doesn't say anything till after they have left and they're leaving. The whole entire time he's at troop farms, he doesn't say a single word. There was a reason it's in deleted scenes. I want you to hear it. Hey guys, I think I'm going to be bad cop and good cop. I'm gonna be like crazy cop, Dwight's root! Come out here with your hands up! I'm so nervous. I feel like I'm gonna save some f***.
这让我很好奇为什么凯文会这么做，他为什么表现得这么奇怪？我在拍摄草稿里发现了更多素材。你可能注意到了，凯文在施鲁特农场时一句话也没说。事实上，你会注意到直到他们离开后，他们正在走的时候他才说话。他在施鲁特农场待的整个时间里，一句话也没说。有个原因，在删减片段里。我想让你听听。嘿伙计们，我想我要当坏警察和好警察。我要当那种疯狂警察，德怀特·施鲁特！举起手出来！我太紧张了。我觉得我要说些脏话了。
K, I'm not gonna spin this. I don't think you should say anything. Yes! Mysterious silent guy. Yes. Starting now. Don't remember shooting that. This is dialogue as you guys are walking up to Shroop Farms. Kevin is having a meltdown.
K，我不会搞砸的。我觉得你不应该说什么。是的！神秘的沉默者。是的。从现在开始。不记得拍过那个。这是你们走向施鲁特农场时的对话。凯文正在崩溃。
He doesn't know how to like, Coke's Dwight or what to say, and you guys are just like, don't say a word, okay? That's pretty great. But that's why when he's like, I don't know, nothing's working, I'll get a skillet. Well also during the scene, Pam has her very famous line that gets quoted back to me all the time, which is Pobody's Nurfect. So cute.
他不知道该怎么哄骗德怀特或者该说什么，你们只是说，别说一个字，好吗？那太棒了。但这就是为什么当他说，我不知道，什么都不管用，我要拿个煎锅。好吧，在那个场景中，帕姆还有一句非常著名的台词，经常被引用，那就是“Pobody's Nurfect”（人非圣贤，孰能无过）。太可爱了。
I had not heard this. When we were shooting, I thought Danny made it up. This phrase, Pobody's nerficked. And I remember Danny was like, no, I had this on a dormat when I was growing up. That's what made him think of it. He's like, yeah, he's like, this has like been around forever. We did not invent this phrase. But people tell me this all the time. It's like that phrase, I'm not as think as do drunk I am or whatever. Yes, that, no know exactly, exactly. But I really like this scene because Pam is so laid back. Andy
我没听说过这个。我们拍摄的时候，我以为是丹尼编的。这个短语，“Pobody's Nurfect”。我记得丹尼说，不，我小时候门垫上有这个。这就是让他想到它的原因。他说，是的，他说，这东西一直都在。我们没有发明这个短语。但人们一直跟我说这个。就像那句短语，“我没醉到我想象的那么清醒”或者别的什么。是的，那个，不，我知道，完全正确，完全正确。但我真的很喜欢这个场景，因为帕姆很随和。安迪
wants to bring up the email. She's like, no, you guys trust me. Dwight will cancel it on his own. I know it. But as they're leaving, they don't know. Dwight walks them out to their car. Pam, thanks him for everything. Dwight and Pam share a sweet little moment, and that's it. Yeah, Dwight says, Sive, Dreyflee. Yes, exactly. While all of that was happening, Darryl and Valor are going to return back to the warehouse. They have coffees for everyone. And Gabe sees his moment. He's gonna make us move. He's gonna say So tonight I was thinking I'm gonna go to the cemetery
想提起那封邮件。她说，不，你们相信我。德怀特会自己取消它的。我知道。但当他们离开时，他们不知道。德怀特把他们送到车边。帕姆感谢他所做的一切。德怀特和帕姆分享了一个甜蜜的小时刻，就这样。是的，德怀特说，Sive, Dreyflee。是的，完全正确。当这一切发生时，达里尔和瓦尔要回到仓库。他们给大家买了咖啡。盖博看到了他的机会。他要采取行动。他说，所以今晚我在想，我要去墓地
I'm gonna drink a little wine and I thought maybe you'd like to come with me Fells like are you asking me on a date Gabe says yes I am and then she very practically says hey, I don't date co-workers. It's not personal. It's a matter of policy He very practically says, hey, I don't date co-workers, it's not personal, it's a matter of policy. Daryl, of course, overhears all of this sort of planting the seed for a later storyline. But Jenna, I just got so hung up on the fact that Gabe thinks a fun first date is going to a cemetery and drinking wine. Lady, that line triggered a memory for me of one of my worst dates I ever went on.
我要喝点红酒，我想也许你想和我一起去。伙计们说，你是在约我吗？盖博说，是的，我是。然后她非常实际地说，嘿，我不和同事约会。这不是针对个人。这是政策问题。他非常实际地说，嘿，我不和同事约会，这不是针对个人，这是政策问题。达里尔当然听到了这一切，这为后来的故事情节埋下了伏笔。但珍娜，我只是纠结于盖博认为有趣的第一次约会是去墓地喝红酒。女士，那句台词触发了我曾经经历过的最糟糕的约会之一的回忆。
I was out of college, I was living back in St. Louis, I was trying to date, and I met a guy in the food court at the mall. Yeah. He was very cute, and I was there shopping by myself, and we were a little flirty, and he asked me if I would like to go to dinner with him And I said yes, I'd love to. Here's my phone number So he calls me and I'm thinking he's taking me to dinner So guess what I didn't do before our date Eat food, right? Because I'm going to dinner Where did he take you? Did he take you to a cemetery?
我大学毕业后，住在圣路易斯，我试着约会，我在商场的美食广场遇到了一个男人。是的。他很可爱，我当时一个人在那儿购物，我们有点调情，他问我愿不愿意和他一起去吃晚饭。我说，是的，我很乐意。这是我的电话号码。所以他给我打电话，我以为他要带我去吃晚饭。所以猜猜我在约会前没做什么？吃东西，对吧？因为我要去吃晚饭。他带你去哪儿了？他带你去墓地了吗？
He took me to his place, his place, being the basement of his parents' home. And I said, where's dinner? And he said, oh, I thought we could order some pizzas later, but first, let's walk up to the train tracks and get stoned with some of my friends. Oh my gosh, oh my lord. And I said, how about you just take me home
他带我去了他家，他家就是他父母家的地下室。我说，晚饭呢？他说，噢，我以为我们晚点可以点些披萨，但首先，让我们走到火车轨道那儿，和我的朋友们一起抽点大麻。天哪，噢，我的天。我说，不如你直接送我回家吧
because I'm f***ing starving, and I don't wanna get stoned with you and your friends at the train tracks and maybe eat pizza later. I don't know. What's, I mean, I tried. I was trying. You were trying, you were trying. Listen, I got very curious about what people are doing
因为我饿死了，我不想和你还有你的朋友在火车轨道那儿抽大麻，也许晚点再吃披萨。我不知道。我是说，我试过了。我当时在努力。你在努力，你在努力。听着，我很好奇人们现在在做什么
for first dates these days. And people are really going for it. They're thinking outside the box. I just wanna read you a few date ideas. If you want something to do that's not your normal first date. This was on list25.com. Are you ready here or a few? Okay. A Nerf war. My God.
第一次约会。人们真的很有创意。他们在跳出框框思考。我只想给你们读几个约会点子。如果你想做点不是普通第一次约会的事情。这是在list25.com上看到的。准备好了吗，这里有几个？好吧。一场Nerf枪战。天哪。
Mm-hmm. Both you and your partner grabbed your favorite Nerf gun and it might sound silly, but acting like a kid can be a real bonding experience. This is a horrible idea. I know. Wait for this one. This one to me sounds like a math problem. I don't feel like doing. A shopping challenge. Grab $20 each and hit your local grocery store. Your job is to buy creative menu items or something you think your partner would enjoy. And then set a time limit and meet back up together at the grocery store. These literally sound like things I do with my kids on the weekends.
嗯哼。你和你的伴侣都拿起你们最喜欢的Nerf枪，这听起来可能很傻，但像孩子一样玩耍可以成为一种真正的联结体验。这是一个糟糕的主意。我知道。等等这个。这个对我来说听起来像个数学题。我不想做。购物挑战。每人拿20美元，去当地的杂货店。你的工作是买有创意的菜单项目或者你认为你的伴侣会喜欢的东西。然后设定一个时间限制，在杂货店重新集合。这些听起来简直就是我周末和孩子们做的事情。
Like, we've done these things. The next one? Visit a fortune teller. Oh my god. At this point, I just want to go to the train tracks or maybe a cemetery and drink wine. The next one is worse, ready? You're gonna hate this one. You're gonna hate it.
就像，我们做过这些事情。下一个？拜访算命先生。噢，天哪。到了这一步，我只想去火车轨道或者也许去墓地喝红酒。下一个更糟，准备好了吗？你会讨厌这个的。你会讨厌它的。
Get lost on purpose. Oh my God. Turn the GPS off and hit the road. Take a highway you've never been on before. And go left when you normally go right. You might discover new things. Make sure you have a full tank of gas. All right, I will say this about the last one.
故意迷路。噢，天哪。关掉GPS，上路吧。走一条你以前从未走过的公路。当你通常向右转时，向左转。你可能会发现新事物。确保你的油箱是满的。好吧，关于最后一点，我会说这个。
I do think that after you've been dating someone for a while, it's a really good idea to try to travel with them, take a road trip, whatever it is because the stresses of travel and being lost, they really bring out a whole other side in a person, and I think that's a really important thing to know when you're discerning whether or not
我确实认为，当你和某人约会一段时间后，尝试和他们一起旅行，公路旅行，无论是什么，都是一个非常好的主意，因为旅行和迷路的压力，它们真的会展现一个人完全不同的一面，我认为在判断这是否会成为
this is gonna be a long-term partner. So, I agree. I agree. That's not a bad date for maybe date, I don't know, like in a couple months in. Okay, I have a few more, but I'm gonna do a rapid fire. Ready? Okay, go ahead.
长期伴侣时，这是一个非常重要的事情。所以，我同意。我同意。对于也许约会，我不知道，几个月后来说，这不是一个坏的约会。好吧，我还有几个，但我会快速说一下。准备好了吗？好吧，继续。
Where else am I going on these amazing dates? Russell and Jello. I mean what? Go Cart Racing. Okay, yes. Go Berry Picking. Take a Segway Tour, volunteer together, and last but not least, this one I think we can get behind. Do a wine and canvas night. Sure. Mm-hmm. Yes. But yeah, wrestle and jello.
我还能去哪儿进行这些惊人的约会？摔跤和果冻。我是说，什么？卡丁车比赛。好吧，是的。去摘浆果。参加赛格威之旅，一起做志愿者，最后但同样重要的是，这个我觉得我们可以支持。做一个红酒和帆布之夜。当然。嗯哼。是的。但，摔跤和果冻。
Shopping challenge. I don't know. So how much jello are you making? What are you putting it in? I would go berry picking. Yeah. All right, should we get back to the squash court, Angela? Yes.
购物挑战。我不知道。所以你要做多少果冻？你把它放在什么里？我会去摘浆果。是的。好吧，我们应该回到壁球场吗，安吉拉？是的。
Jim and Robert are going to play squash. And Jim clearly doesn't know how to play. We had a fan question from Melissa A. in Brooklyn, New York. Did John Krasinski and James Bader have to do any special training to play squash? Please tell me they did. They did not. They did not. Steve Burgess said we shot this at a real squash club called 360 health and recita.
吉姆和罗伯特要去打壁球。吉姆显然不知道怎么打。我们收到了来自纽约布鲁克林的梅丽莎·A的粉丝提问。约翰·卡拉辛斯基和詹姆斯·贝德需要进行任何特殊训练来打壁球吗？请告诉我他们做了。他们没有。他们没有。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们在雷西达一个叫360健康与娱乐的真实壁球俱乐部拍摄的。
They did absolutely no prep and in fact the ball was added in post What Jim and Robert are faking? He said they added the ball later to match their movements and he said if you notice that when they stop playing to get the phone There is no ball rolling around the floor. It just disappears. Oh my gosh. That's so crazy that there was no ball. Well, Jim is going to hit his squash balls, unfortunately. And there was no ball in that stunt, so John really sold it. Way to go, John. But you know, Robert is going to get a little ding on his phone and Jim's going to have
他们根本没有做任何准备，事实上球是后期加进去的。吉姆和罗伯特在假装？他说他们后来加了球来匹配他们的动作，他说如果你注意到当他们停止打球去拿手机时，地板上没有球滚来滚去。它直接消失了。天哪。没有球真是太疯狂了。好吧，吉姆要打他的壁球了，不幸的是。那个特技里没有球，所以约翰真的演得很像。干得好，约翰。但你知道，罗伯特的手机会响一下，吉姆得
to go over and grab it. He clearly tries to break it by throwing it to Robert, but it turns out that it was just an email from JetBlue advertising some specials. It was not the Doomstay device, Dwight canceled it. And then he has a really sweet talking head where he explains why. He says, you know, these aren't his favorite people. He wouldn't even call him friends. But, you know, to come over and help a guy dig a grave and eat his pie, you know, they clearly got to him. He's going to work with them forever, isn't he? got to him. He's gonna work with them forever, isn't he? Yeah. Well Pam also had a talking head. I remember. It's really great. It's so sweet.
过去拿它。他显然试图通过把它扔给罗伯特来弄坏它，但结果那只是捷蓝航空发来的一封广告邮件。那不是末日装置，德怀特取消了它。然后他有一个非常甜蜜的采访镜头，他解释了原因。他说，你知道，这些人不是他最喜欢的人。他甚至不会称他们为朋友。但是，你知道，过来帮一个人挖坟墓并吃他的派，你知道，他们显然打动了他。他会和他们永远一起工作，不是吗？打动了他。他会和他们永远一起工作，不是吗？是的。好吧，帕姆也有一个采访镜头。我记得。真的很棒。太甜蜜了。
It's in deleted scenes. I want you guys all to hear it. Sometimes you just have to let people know they're being heard and valued. I don't get how everyone doesn't see that. Yeah. I mean, I feel like the writers saw you do that talking head and loved it and it's part of the reason why Pam's character has the final talking head of the series because it- Oh my gosh, that's so sweet, Angela. It's true. When I watched it, I had that same feeling of just, ugh, you know, my heart just was so warmed by the fact that these people are their co-workers, but they've become this misfit family, you know, my heart just was so warmed by the fact that these people are their co-workers,
在删减片段里。我想让你们都听听。有时候你只需要让人们知道他们被倾听和重视。我不明白为什么每个人都看不到这一点。是的。我是说，我觉得编剧们看到你做那个采访镜头并爱上了它，这就是帕姆的角色拥有该系列最后一个采访镜头的部分原因。噢，天哪，那太甜蜜了，安吉拉。这是真的。当我观看时，我也有同样的感觉，只是，呃，你知道，我的心被这些人是他们的同事，但他们已经成为了这个不合群的家庭这一事实温暖了，你知道，我的心被这些人是他们的同事，
but they've become this misfit family, you know. Well, during these talking heads, there's a whole thing going on in the background, which is that Dwight is getting a hat out of the ground. This is a hat that the group gave him when they arrived. Yeah. It's a son of co-hat, and we got a really cool piece of fan mail about this hat. It comes from Dan R in Westchester, Pennsylvania, who said, When the Doomsday episode first aired in November 2011, I was working at the Sanoco Marcus
但他们已经成为了这个不合群的家庭这一事实温暖了，你知道。好吧，在这些采访镜头期间，背景里发生了一整件事，那就是德怀特正在从地里拿出一顶帽子。这是他们到达时团队给他的帽子。是的。这是一顶“太阳石油公司”的帽子，我们收到了一封关于这顶帽子的非常酷的粉丝邮件。它来自宾夕法尼亚州西切斯特的丹·R，他说，当《末日》这一集在2011年11月首次播出时，我在费城附近的太阳石油公司马库斯
Hoke refinery near Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. And the day before the episode aired, the company communications director emailed all the employees telling us to be sure to tune in to the office because Sonoco made a special appearance. Everyone was excited to tune in, but after the episode ended, we were in shock. The storyline for the episode with potential firing of employees
霍克炼油厂工作。在剧集播出前一天，公司通讯主管给所有员工发了电子邮件，告诉我们要确保收看《办公室》，因为太阳石油公司特别出镜了。每个人都很兴奋地收看，但在剧集结束后，我们震惊了。这一集的故事情节涉及潜在的员工解雇
and threatening a shutdown of the branch, it really hit home because we were having some internal issues that were similar at the time. And I have been wondering all of this time for 11 years plus, did someone write this episode knowing about our company situation or was it a coincidence? Oh my gosh. Dan, this is a coincidence. This is just, I think, every company all the time, right? Deals with these things.
和威胁关闭分部，这真的触动了我们的心，因为我们当时也有类似的内部问题。我这11年来一直想知道，是不是有人在知道我们公司情况的情况下写了这一集，还是巧合？噢，天哪。丹，这是一个巧合。这只是，我想，每家公司一直都在处理这些事情，对吧？这就是为什么我们可以做一整集关于追踪错误或关于潜在分部关闭的内容。这是一种公司事务。对于任何不知道的人，太阳石油公司在宾夕法尼亚州有加油站。这个想法很简单，他们只是想在路上给德怀特买点礼物，他们去了加油站，拿了这顶帽子。就这样。是的。
It's why we could do a whole episode about tracking mistakes or about potential branch closures. This is kind of corporate stuff. For anyone who doesn't know, Sonoco has gas stations in Pennsylvania. And the idea was simply that they wanted to pick something up as a gift for Dwight on their way and they went to a gas station and they grabbed this hat. That's it. Yeah.
这就是动机。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们必须获得使用这顶帽子的许可，太阳石油公司总部批准了看到标志，雷恩·威尔逊甚至签了几顶他们寄回来的帽子供人们拥有。所有的反馈只是他们喜欢看到德怀特戴着他们的帽子。就是这么简单。是的。好吧，结局好一切都好。末日装置被停用了。
That was the motivation. Steve Burgess said we had to get permission to use the hat and Sonoco corporate gave their permission to see the logo and Rainwellson even signed a couple of hats that they sent back for people to have. And all the feedback was just that they loved seeing Dwight wear one of their hats. It was as simple as that. Yeah. Well, all's well that ends well. The Doomstay device is deactivated.
然而，斯坦利现在将不得不为他工作的最后一天买我们的新白兰地。是的，他整集都在喝它。我在拍摄草稿里看到他实际上开始给菲利斯倒了一些，他们两个在角落里有点头晕目眩。完美。好吧，非常感谢你们收听并发送你们的问题和评论。再次感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯为我们提供幕后细节。也感谢丹尼·陈和我发邮件。
Stanley, however, is now going to have to get our new brandy for his last day of work. Yes, he's been the all up the episode drinking it. I saw in the shooting draft that he actually starts pouring some for Phyllis and the two of them are just sort of giddy in the corner. Perfect. Well thank you guys so much for listening and sending in your questions and comments. Thank you to Steve Burgess once again for giving us behind the scenes details. And thank you Danny Chan for emailing with me as well.
是的。我们希望你们这周剩下的时间过得愉快，我们下周会回来和你们聊天。萨姆，打嗝？不幸的是，还在持续。噢，不，萨姆。我知道。好吧。好吧。
Yes. We hope you guys have a great rest of the week, and we'll be back next week to chat with you. Sam, hiccups? Unfortunately, going strong. Oh, no, Sam. I know. All right. All right.
好吧，如果你们有什么治疗打嗝的方法，私信我们，我们下期见。噢，不。我是说，我真的希望萨姆在这一集播出时打嗝已经好了。噢，天哪，我也希望如此。好吧，你们这周剩下的时间过得愉快。我们下周见。到时候见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。
Well, if you guys have any remedies for hiccups, DMS, and we'll see you here next. Oh, no. I mean, I really hope that Sam doesn't still have the hiccups by the time this episode comes out. Oh my gosh, I hope not too. Alright, well you guys have a great rest of the week. We'll see you next week. See you then! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
《办公室女士》由Earwool、詹妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制片人是安斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问stichopremium.com。如需免费试用一个月stichopremium，请使用代码office。你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to stichopremium.com. For a free one one month trial of stitur premium use code office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Earwool、Jennifer Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的高级制作人是Cassie Jerkins。我们的录音室工程师是Sam Keifer。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是Jordan Duffy，我们的助理制作人是Ainsley Bubbaco。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。如需收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问stichopremium.com。使用代码office可免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。